what don't you like about pancakes
sometimes it just feels like a whole lot
of the same exact thing just bread wait
you're saying pancakes are just bread is
that it's just bread and then you put
syrup on it and it's the same thing bite
after bite after bite I've had some
pancakes that changed my life too though
no I have news for you pal what any food
yet is the same thing fine after bite
that's how Food Works there's not many
things you eat a stack of yeah I mean
you got some balls you can play that
either way you can play that either way
it's like I don't think I like to eat a
stack of the same food but then why is
it served as a stack because people want
that much of it no it's because they're
cheap and they're trying to rip you off
have you ever tried to make pancakes it
is no walk in the park
thank you
just his head it is no walk in the park